there goes the yummy if I can get
through this it makes you stronger
welcome to day 6 of our Europe adventure
we're gonna show what happened today but
first we need to talk
[Music]
so it's been a rough past couple days
first for everybody who's been hardcore
in the series I apologized last night on
last week's video I guess I didn't I
didn't close it off you should have an
ending message what happened was it came
back to the cabin and I felt okay and
then then immediately felt nauseous like
I was gonna throw up
yeah out of nowhere not even like little
minor sense out of nowhere so I put that
I put the patch on and dope in the bed
at 8:30 and we are going through a with
hurricane yeah a very rare European
hurricane and it's only hitting Greece
and so yes yeah maybe it's the best
stuck in a bit of a hurricane so last
night was brutal yeah last night wasn't
it all night last night was the worst
yeah up and down and up and down and up
and down want to vomit multiple times
well you are pretty little your pretty
little then we both got sick Nina's sick
nina hasn't been sick in a long time I'm
not sick she's saying she's not sick but
she's sneezing and coughing and
sniffling what does that mean just
normal
allergy right we can't go to Athens
because of the weather so we got
sidetracked to the knee oh I forgot the
name it's it's past 12:30 we got here at
8:00 we've been lying in bed and
relaxing until now and so we're gonna
have a pretty light day we're gonna
explore the city but still film videos
for you guys even though I'm sick and
then we can have our massage book the
five o'clock ready to go yeah let's go
[Music]
it is a chilly day here in Greece first
stop famous coffee shop it's warm
[Music]
the finest ronberry coffee there
you liked it good strike
how's the coffee in big style
suite-style strong you you had courage
to try the local one is very strong it's
like cappuccino
okay connects with the old town do some
videos for you guys and then get some
food
[Music]
Nina had a good idea pharmacy go look
for some nyquil yeah we love you Nina
all right we got contracts it's supposed
to make you drowsy at night we're not a
hundred percent sure everything is in
Greek so we'll give it a shot we'll give
it a shot Nina let's see it's so so bad
in there
I'm congested I can't smell anything no
I'm fully blocked
[Music]
okay next stop lunch at a famous local
restaurant
let's get Nina some good food
yeah Yolo
when use handwritten Oh sticky Oh crazy
around one whatever this is
[Music]
[Music]
look at Nina's excitement for the salad
that's a happy Nina face alright give it
a shot get a bit of everything in there
[Music]
okay calamari schnitzel I like crab
we'll see kram but whatever okay try the
come fire in the American see what you
got
look at that face she squeezes the push
push face here it is this is it moment
of truth
let's hot you stick the whole thing in
good just hot
alright okay [ __ ] it sometime
also hot closing it up in some ways of
hairs let's see
apple cinnamon yummy you're kind of like
apple cinnamon of honey like Chinese
apple cinnamon honey too sweet are you
gonna like it then we got some Greek
alcohol start you know that's a full
glass you didn't take anything
you have to down it yeah that's why he
gave me a shot glass no no no I've
noticed here goes
you feel better how's your calm
you cop this guy cold this gun Steve
some Creek alcohol it's burning your
face I'm so glad I didn't have it okay
we love you neither
okay you're gonna cry boy tell us a
story we love you
I feel Annina it does yeah I mean the
salad was super fresh food was different
unique I really liked the squid is my
favorite so far Greece needed that
wasn't as big of Fang I personally yeah
I liked it I just like the batter wasn't
that big anyway one thing I didn't I
didn't share this morning I go in his
story time with Evan
so last night I had two moments I had
two moments where I felt like panicking
yeah yeah I'm panicking because I'm
lying in bed this walk slowly so I can
hold this I'm lying in bed and I had to
sneeze I had to cough my nose is
dripping and I felt like throwing up all
at the same time and it's like we
couldn't get off the boat I felt trapped
it's like I can't get help like I like a
closet public like I'm stuck in him in a
box or something but I was I was
actually stuck but no options right I
was like having a panic attack
yeah but then as soon as start having it
something this is how messed up I am
because I started having it
what yeah I'm putting my son as soon as
sort of having it like 30 seconds later
maybe not even maybe 15 seconds later
like this is the best
because I'm like if I can get through
this it makes you stronger because I've
never had like I've never been
claustrophobic reading that kind of
sounds like this is this is a great
experiences this negativity this happen
right now is feeling like trapped panic
attack is great because I can handle
more now see that's how my stuff oh yeah
but okay that's not to tell you that
okay
look at us twins hoodie guys look Vijay
sir
okay back to the boat relax film videos
massage
[Music]
okay did you not know I have it I don't
let it nap I lay down burn the crash
they're laid out did not make videos yet
I need to make videos you know I know I
crouched there but the video is gonna be
like hey guys shot heads for his head
whatever is gonna happen it's gonna
happen not making videos is not that
happening not making peace is not an
option so anyway what are we doing now
massage what kind of massage deep tissue
I'm gonna ask for neck and shoulders and
hands you're gonna go for it let's show
some hint hint but no that's not the
same as hands neck shoulders pant neck
shoulders and body
let's hope it's real this is our room
about to go in
there's Nina's bed this is mine and we
have to get completely naked except for
this is what I need to wear excitement
Mina's laughing all right let's do it
guys
exciting Thank You Lee Nieman gets to
show their blade action you gotta show
me so I can do it like a good husband
right the you jihad mind have a great
spite of my foot pushing the spine of my
foot yeah and I think I felt it in my
head like oh man so you got to learn how
to do the foot near this fishy massager
yeah not the outside though not how I
like it anyway you know what I realized
I almost laughed on the table because
because just before we you know that the
word that crazy thought I was
embarrassed but what is embarrassed okay
good I'm bare asked I was literally bare
asked I'm embarrassed
hey that's fine what's the plan back to
the room relax
[Music]
okay so good news bad news good news is
it's gonna be less choppy even last
night
the bad news is still gonna be choppy
it's hard to imagine it being equally
choppy the last night that was
ridiculous but it's gonna be better
tonight so that's good
Nina's bringing us good luck that's a
finding that you're gonna - what do you
think hopefully it's a decent night if
you both use some sleep but before that
eat dinner time
[Music]
alright okay I like that
[Music]
all right I got my tea with lemon can
had some honey Nina got her
alcohol and fruit plate we're gonna head
back to the cabin you guys are not
invited if you guys want to see the fun
that we had yesterday in Olympia and the
view from the mountaintop cafe clicked a
mini right next to us I think you'll
enjoy continue to and we'll see you
there
thank you know about the donkeys near
ready